c'est dit que c'est le papa puis c'est
le papa des papiers un corot
[Musique]
david r
dans l'âme beaucoup d'émotion à 0 2 nous
courons en attendant mon nom en d'un
grand génie
[Musique]
ces couleurs qui avaient des enfants
avec les autochtones et avec des
militaires il y avait des idées des gens
qui travaillent dans l'agriculture qui
venaient en mission l'a quittée du
passage et s'offre étaient abandonnés
ici en côte d'ivoire et pour leur donner
une éducation la maison coloniale de
l'époque décide d'ouvrir cet espace là
non
[Musique]
que mon père était ce qu'ils appelaient
qu'on en sait quelque chose comme ça et
passer son temps faire des tournées à
travers la côte d'ivoire et quand il est
arrivé dans ma région
ma mère a été le cadeau pour un de biens
devenus qu'on lui a offert leur histoire
a duré 48 heures d'après ce que ma mère
m
on nous étions pupille de l'état donc
enfants français et donc si nous sommes
les enfants de la france comment
pouvons-nous ne pas être français ça et
c'est une aberration
il avait souhaité avoir ma mère comme
une femme pour passer le temps et c'est
comme ça que je suis dit quand on
connaît l'histoire après ça fait mal
[Musique]